c'est une belle victoire pour nous en
tout cas il n'avait pas encore gagné sur
you tube never gagné d'étape mon coeur
est vraiment envie de gagner une
première étape donc à point alma les
jeunes mais on va voir comment ça j'ai
dit justement cette compétition pour
vous pour votre et bien déjà c'est de
mouiller d'essayer de jouer avec les
gones ans donc on va voir jusqu'à 10
mois je commence à se passer est-ce que
vous avez vous traite quelqu'un à
surveiller sur on a tous vu des cantons
sont vous savez une course entièrement
de rebondissements donc il faut toujours
être attentif et serein faut pouvoir
jouer avec les plus gros et puis
pourquoi vous avez collaboré un courrier
aux on vous a vu enfin de cause et parle
un peu avec lui oui on a collaboré ont
cessé d soutiennent qu'ils qui jouait
pour les marges ont donc on a vraiment
roulé jusqu'à la fin et puis on s'est
mis vraiment côte à côte pour le plus
fort qui gagne au sprint sur six c'est
comme ça quand on est complet on
n'essaie pas de doublé en est on essaie
de vraiment gagner avec la force des
gens